بهذه الاجواء الحماسيه تجمع انصار الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام مبنى
مقر ولايه ساوث كارولينا احدى ولايات
التصويت المبكر في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التمهيديه
مئات الجمهوريين قدموا من مختلف انحاء
الولايه المهمه في الانتخابات التمهيديه
الى عاصمتها كولومبيا لدعم ترامب وتعزيز
حظوظه في الترشح رغم ان استطلاعات للراي
تظهروا عدد من الجمهوريين في الولايه
يرغبون في ترشح شخص اخر لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه نيوز
ايييان
مراد
الذين فازوا بالانتخابات التمهيديه في
ولايه الساوث كارولينا حصلوا على تزكيه
حزبهم لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه لهذا ينظر
الى هذه الولايه كبوصله في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه
ترامب الذي كان محاط بابرز مؤيديه في ساوث
كارولينا ومنهم السيناتور عن الولايه
لينزي غرام والحاكم ماستر لم يغير من نمره
خطابه المعتاده
سايبر
تفكر في الترشح مثل السفيره الامريكيه
السابقه لدى الامم المتحده
حسين الطاوضه من ولايه سوسكارولينا
العربيه
[تصفيق]